meeting will be audio recorded
please switch off mobiles or turn them
onto
site silent
members please be upstanding to receive
the chairman
the council chairman's chaplain and the
acting managing director
i'm going to start by giving you a line
from scripture from evening prayer this
evening
psalm 10 verse 18. lord you will hear
the desire of the poor
you will incline your ear to the
fullness of their heart
to give justice to the orphan and
oppressed so that people are no longer
driven in terror from the land
so let us pray father god as we gather
this evening we're aware that there are
still some who are in terror
in our land because of coronavirus we
lift you those in our districts who are
clinically vulnerable
those concerns for loved ones those
frightened by the thought of life
returning to normal
as national legal restrictions lift we
give thanks for all who have worked so
hard
locally in our nhs and volunteering to
help others
we give thanks for all council officials
and employees who've enabled services to
continue
in difficult times and almighty god from
whom comes every good and perfect gift
we pray that this meeting will be
conducted in a spirit of justice
truth wisdom and charity we pray that
mindful of their responsibility and of
the needs of those they serve
each councillor and officer may use
their influence
in this meeting to promote the build-up
of community and neighbourhood
help them seek the way of love and peace
through him who is the prince of peace
our savior jesus christ amen
i'd like to thank the reverend nick
rowan
for your time you are welcome to stay or
if you do have other duties please take
your leave
thank you members please take a seat
and
can everyone hear me okay no
is that any better
good evening members and welcome to this
meeting
of the full council can you hear me okay
members there are four microphones that
are on the tables
for use during the meeting when i invite
you to speak
please wait until there is a microphone
in front of you
before speaking as the microphones are
needed for the hearing loop
and for the audio recording please where
possible
assist in passing microphones to each
other
and use the hand gel and antibacterial
wipes
on the tables if you do touch the
microphones
members voting will be done on a show of
hands
in line with the constitution
i will ask for a show of hands for
and then against recommendations and
then
for abstaining given the size of this
room
and the numbers of us present can i
please ask that you put your hand up
decisively
higher in the air so that we can be
clearly seen and leave it up until i ask
you to lower it
members we're now going to move on to
agenda item
number one apologies for absence
apologies i have received are from
councillor carter
councillor mrs carter councillor smith
who is currently having to self-isolate
and councillor webb
and councillor mrs mason
are there any other apologies counsellor
mr
mro
thank you councillor
any other
okay thank you members we'll now move
yes just one moment
okay moving on to our agenda item two
minutes of the meeting held on the 18th
of may 2021
members are you happy for me to sign the
minutes of the annual council meeting
held on the 18th of may is that agreed
members
thank you
councillor wilkinson
oh
sorry thank you jeff i wasn't ignoring
it um chairman just on a point of order
um
i have a conversation with the
democratic services regarding the
minutes that were circulated in the fact
that there was an error because
they don't comply with the constitution
because there's no voting numbers on
there
i was told that was going to be amended
um if it has been amended i haven't
received a copy of it
because it hasn't i haven't received it
so i can't confirm if that's correct i
don't know if any other member has but
the ones i've got
are the ones that were sent out at the
end of may which
we can't agree on thank you councillor
wilkinson
these have been amended thank you
just before we continue members it is
very hot tonight and if you wish to
remove your jackets for your comfort
please do so
okay so members are we in agreement
with the minutes that have been amended
agreed thank you
moving on to agenda item two
we've just done that sorry
agenda item three declarations of
interest do
we have any declarations of interest
counsellor mrs rowe thank you
thank you councillor
councillor mr dry
thank you madam chairman i'd like to
declare a non-pecuniary interest
again in item number 12 cctv as a member
for wheatley ward on raley town council
thank you council dre councillor
williams
thank you madam chairman i'd like to um
give a non-purchasing
interest on item 12 as being a member of
the rochester parish council
thank you councilman councillor expiry
thank you chairman nonparty interest and
item number 12 as being a member of
brady town council
thank you
campaign council
thank you
councillor robin
yes chairman um i'd declare a non-cuban
test as a member town council for item
12.
thank you
councillor ward
um yes just to declare a non-pecuniary
interest
item 12 as a member of raleigh town
council
thank you
counselor canal do you have your hand up
thank you chair as all other members uh
item
12 non-puna interest uh by way of being
a radio town councillor
thank you councillor newport
item 12 non-pecuniary interest as a
member of ready town council
thank you
councillor fd
same again item 12 washington parish
council
interest thank you councillor fd
councillor goodin
non-pecuniary interest for item 12 it's
by the way the fact i'm a member of
rochford parish council
thank you councillor hazelwood
pecuniary interest in a member of
hockley parish council
council sorry
councilman pearson
stanley please
item 12 german non-security interest
thank you
okay members before we continue
with the main business of the meeting i
would like to move a motion
without notice in line with the council
procedure rule
14c to take item 13
the joint strategic partnership next as
we have visitors present for this item
and they may wish to leave the meeting
early
do i have a second please thank you
councillor steptoe
can those that are for please vote so
thank you members you can now lower your
hands can those
against please raise their hands right
up and keep them up while the officers
count them
and don't lower them until i ask you to
do so
and finally those who wish to abstain
please raise
you can lower your hand apologies
finally can those members wishing to
abstain please raise your hands
thank you members that is 25 4
1 against and five of stone
that motion is carried
so agenda item 13
the joint strategic partnership i will
ask the leader of the council to
introduce the report
and the council's acting managing
director will then take
us through a presentation the leader
will then conclude his report
counsellor mr wood
thank you madam chairman i think i'm
fortunate enough to have one of those
watches which may
reach around the room
thank you for the benefit of the
recording
thank you madam chairman i'm very
pleased to bring this report to before
members this evening
following the retirement of the managing
director on the 31st of october 2020
a paper was brought to council in
december 2020
it was agreed in that paper that in
conjunction with the acting
managing director and on behalf of the
executive
i as leader would initially explore the
opportunity to establish a shared
management arrangement with another
local authority
as set out and detailed in paragraph 2.3
it made sense at that time to look at
the five
in other essex at a very early stage
it became apparent from discussions that
brentwood borough council
were also in a state where they had an
appetite as a broad possibility
of some sort of sharing services with
another authority
or a partnership arrangement
the red line for both authorities was to
protect
and preserve individual council's
sovereignty
whilst at the same time creating a
strong
strategic partnership with no shared
boundary
the arrangement we're proposing tonight
achieves
just that at this point
i will ask the acting managing director
to present some slides to us
which will set our vision in a bit more
detail
thank you thank you councillor
chairman if i may remain seated just to
take through these slides thank you yes
go for it
uh members as as i as council orton has
explained this began as
a conversation between two uh
authorities that were looking for
mutual opportunities for improvement
this slide sets out the journey that
brentwood borough council undertook to
bring them to this point
and they had been having discussions
with other authorities
um but that coincided with the
discussions with
us and our journey to find um a new
head of paid service and uh for the
vacant managing director
post the pro preferred partners uh we
both agreed should be
of the same tier within a 30-mile radius
i.e within south essex to ensure
i beg your pardon
counselor sonny can you hear me now okay
thank you
i will just go back one slide
so the partnership opportunities for
brentwood borough council
are as set out on the slide um the
opportunity to work with us because of
the vacant managing director post
and a willingness to explore a
partnership approach
is what coincided with our journey to
this point as
as uh councillor whitten has outlined
the uh preferred partners we are both
within the same tier
second-tier authorities we're both
members of south essex
which means that so far as compatibility
is concerned we have same vision and
outlook
the same agenda and an equality of
um bargaining power
this slide demonstrates a little bit
more around the
similarities of scale geography and
economy
which makes this a proposed partnership
of equals
our revenue budgets are broadly similar
our geographies and demographics
similarly so although as you can see our
governance and election
our governance cycles are very different
i think this is probably the most
important slide that
members should focus on is what the
partnership could be and most certainly
what it is not and i think it is
important to remember that this is not
a devolution or a a cessation of any
autonomy or sovereignty on part of the
council
it is a mechanism to ensure that
partnership can
create resilience and to share services
where required to create economies of
scale
to move money spent on back office
services in particular
to front line delivery and to strengthen
our relationships
in terms of how we operate across south
essex and across the county more
generally
the um the important thing is in terms
of
autonomy the council remains a sovereign
body in its own right
and this council and you as elected
members will retain
authority in respect of all matters
relating to
this council
the proposal as per the report is that
there is an interim
joint chief executive managing director
and that is the
incumbent uh chief executive officer at
brentwood borough council jonathan
stevenson
and that he would be appointed for a
period of six months
to take up this joint role across both
authorities
uh and uh members that is the subject of
this paper and that is the
uh to which the recommendation relates
um
working alongside jonathan would be
myself and my counterpart steve summers
who is the strategic director at
brentwood borough council
members there that would operate under
existing delegations to the head of
paid service so there is no need for a
specific recommendation in respect
of the strategic director roles
this slide essentially just sets out the
proposed next steps um
with the decision today and then a
period of time for development of an
overall business case
for the strategic alliance to be brought
forward heading towards
um a decision to proceed on a more
formal basis towards the end of the year
and for paperwork to be brought back and
report to be brought back to council for
that decision to be made
members the recommendation is for a
six-month arrangement
notwithstanding that we hope to complete
things as matters
within that time scale firstly because
that allows work to be done and
report to be held by the end of the year
including any slippage and to
enable synchronization of the
reporting cycles for both authorities
and
of course also to allow handover at the
end of february
if a decision is taken not to proceed
with this relationship at the end of
this calendar year
members i have that's the end of the
presentation if i could hand back to
councillor wootton
thank you to the acting managing
director
angela hutchings madam chairman if i
move to the second
part of my uh introduction my
proposal this evening moving forward the
proposal is set out
in paragraph 3.4 which reads
the proposal is to agree to share a
joint chief executive
managing director for an initial
six-month period
to develop an initial feasibility study
business case
and proposals for future development of
shared services
to understand the management and
political aspirations
needs and priorities of each council to
be able to determine the most
effective partnership opportunities
appropriate for both councils
moving forward consideration of the
options
for the sharing model going forward and
the necessary governance arrangements
required
and to produce a timetable for
implementation with milestones
and estimated financial efficiency
savings
paragraphs 3.5 to 3.9 then go on to set
out the mechanics
of how that would be achieved
at that point madam chairman with your
agreement
and before i read out and go on to the
recommendations in the report
i'm happy to take any questions or hear
any comments
before i move to the recommendations
thank you councillorton
councillor wilkinson
thank you chairman um i'm not sure if
this question is best for the leader or
the acting management director um the
one of the slides
has got i think it's the previous one to
the one that's up there at the moment it
uses the terminology
interim joint strategic director and
twice actually
would i be right in thinking that if we
were to go ahead with this
angela would effectively go back to her
previous role purely for rockford
and steve summers were purely for
brentwood what is the
the idea of the joint side of things
because are we now sharing strategic
directors as well as
the ceo does that make sense thank you
thank you
thank you council wilkinson i'm happy to
answer that question the proposal is
that the strategic director roles will
be shared
across both organizations to provide
resilience and
also to provide capacity
the as i mentioned in my presentation
there's no requirement for a
recommendation to that effect because
that delegation can be done under the
delegations which exist
in respect of the head of paid service
in any event so it would be
around both myself and steve summers
working across both authorities
thank you council ahoy thank you
chairman um councilor wilkinson asked my
first question that's been answered very
well thank you
um i i'm a little disappointed in the
way this has come forward to the council
i understand
that it's perfectly legitimate to do so
in this way i would have rather seen it
go through the
chief officer appointment committee even
though i know we're not appointing a
chief
officer in the normal way with this
is the agreement specifically to appoint
jonathan stevenson or is it to appoint
the chief executive officer of brentwood
borough council
i saw because the agreement is with
brentwood borough council and i just
want to make sure that
he is named in that agreement as the
first question
the second concern
is that i think um andrew hutchins did
mention this or
briefly is that politically the
governance
is very different the brentwood do
operate a committee system
and we operate a cabinet system
obviously as
i'm sure many members here would know
that i would have no objection to going
to a committee system
but i doubt if that's the intention of
the leader
of this council at this time can the
leader just comment on
how he feels the the
how he feels jonathan stephen sunken
will be able to not cope that's the
wrong word but to
to understand the differences in working
with the different systems they are very
different in how they work and how
and and and how decisions are made
they're really the the last two
questions thank you
the chief officer uh appointments
committee that is not the appropriate
body at this stage
and i think you sort of alluded to that
you made your point and then
sort of answered your own question
in respect of the organisation
thank you madam chair um in the report
there is uh on page section uh page 13.5
recommendation 9.1 brackets
5. there is a recommendation that the
monitoring officer
be given delegated authority to make any
required changes
to the constitution and i've got a
concern over this because
within the body of the report there is
no rationale
why that should should take place and
from my perspective it means
there's no there's no um oversight of
this
and i would have thought it would have
been better for this to come back to
council to be ratified
and i i would perhaps prefer to see the
word draft in there
rather than to make the required changes
thank you
thank you councillor wilson
council wilson yes
um no any changes that come forward from
this decision will naturally
be a factual changes which will as
council you will give me delegated
authority to change
um any following a report that's to come
back to council
um later on this year any further
changes then or factual nature will
again
be for uh council to delegate to myself
as a monitoring officer to change
thank you councillor milne
please
uh thank you yeah this is a question uh
for the leader and
and uh for our executive
uh basically apart from the the saving
of monies
in salary in the report how do we
perceive
what the other advantages will be of
employing mr stevenson in that
there obviously our difficulties getting
top-end ceos
at the right the right money to actually
uh
give us a sort of extra edge so have we
we looked at that in our
selection process as it were for for
brentwood thank you
thank you councilman councillor
thank you madam chairman uh i think uh
you also councillor milne
sort of answered your own question in
the sense that if you go back to the
options that were presented to council
in the december meeting
it was quite a clear mandate to go and
look at
shared arrangements now within the paper
it alludes to the benefits of shared
arrangements
and the challenges that authorities are
facing all over the country financial
um the opportunities that partnerships
actually present which actually
in modern times are actually stronger
when you work in partnership with people
rather than when you work singularly but
i can't
move away from the fact that the market
is a competitive place
and to seek the managing director stroke
chief executive
of the caliber that we would require is
certainly
a challenge for authorities of our size
thank you council orton uh i'll take
councillor eves and then count
sorry councillor easton council foster
thank you chair i've got three
questions come points uh
section 6.3 in the report
uh does actually talk about the
employment
of this particular situation
the direct employment is with uh with
brentwood
the concern with that is if that there
is any reason
why that employment falls apart how does
rochford stand
because obviously we are not directly
employing him
and if he falls out of favor with
brentwood
where does that leave us that's one
i did ask on email for the
practical arrangements as to how this
would work
would it be that jonathan would be
available
on certain times certain days of the
week to rochford
and in the event of that being the case
if he was then not in the area when
or not dedicated to the area when
something important came up
that required his uh actual attention
how would that work this this is the
machinery of it rather than the person
and the other thing is that in the
recommendations we
have got all the recommendations are
looking to ways of going forward
but i think that we need to actually
have part of the recommendations there
to review
how the six months have gone to be able
to actually understand
if this is going to be positive for
rochford in the future
thank you chair thank you
council lawton thank you madam chairman
um councillor eves uh you're doing
what is an actual temptation to do is
you're actually
moving into the interim arrangements
while we actually sort out exactly the
points that you've made
the direct employment situation is a
question that will be answered over uh
while the interim arrangements are
sorted out
it is perhaps a little bit much to
expect on the night that we're
introducing this report to be able to
have all those very detailed but very
fair
answers so the answer is uh that will be
taken account of
in the uh in the intro period that we're
talking about in this
in this report in terms of availability
well um i i guess it depends on the
person doesn't it really
how well they make themselves available
but i do think
we have got to get to a situation where
we can't just expect everyone always to
be on the end of a phone
and the appropriateness of the inquiry
that we are making
there is a bit of a temptation i think
for all councillors to
want to expect assistant directors or
the managing director to always be
on the end of the telephone the moment
that
they request them to be there all i
would say
is my early meetings with
jonathan stevenson i can assure you on a
24
7 basis you will have absolutely no
problem
getting hold of it and
in terms of sorry your last point was
catharines
i think that's really what the interim
report is all about to do just that
and to bring that back at the end of the
uh we're hoping
we're hoping it will be even sooner than
six months but
we've said six months and uh certainly
your point is noted
thank you thank you i'll take councillor
foster and then council canal
and i think we've had a good discussion
there
thank you madam chairman as we all know
all councils have an obligation
to provide services to our communities
as effectively
and efficiently as possible bringing
fresh eyes into an organization can
bring new ideas
and drive improvement sharing a chief
executive
managing director and partnering with a
council with similar interests
scale and economy as this proposal
suggests
indeed could identify and stimulate
new ideas for the rochford district
council area
without eroding our sovereignty
i see this as a no risk proposition
in six months time a business case and
detailed plans
will be uh provided and that will be the
decision point for the long-term future
to my mind the proposal makes great
sense
thank you thank you councillor council
canal
thank you um
my questions actually been answered by a
combination of council leaders in
council autumn thank you
council lawton
thank you madam chairman i'm just
conscious that the
sign language between the managing
director and myself broke down
on the second question that councillor
hoy
asked um
right okay just before i move to the
recommendations madam chairman
i do at this point just want to publicly
pay tribute to
angela hutchings who
not only has worked so constructively
and very positively
in this little exercise um working with
me principally
on working with potential partners and
arriving at a
solution but also her sterling work
to lead and support rockford district
council
for this past nine months through what
has clearly been
one of the most difficult times of
our history it will go down in history
for all sorts of reasons but angela has
kept the ship very steady and
i really appreciate both the personal
support that she's given to me
but i also think that all members should
be very appreciative of the support that
her and her team have provided to us
through turbulent times i think i'll
leave it there
the other thing is that whilst he is
keeping a low profile this evening
um it would be extremely discourteous of
me
not to acknowledge that jonathan
stevenson
is sitting in the crowd at the back and
i think you just ought to stand jonathan
there is jonathan coming to observe our
meeting
welcome jonathan albeit that there will
be an occasion to
hopefully more
thank you foreign attending our meeting
and also if i may uh the leader of
brentwood council chris hossack was in a
meeting at six o'clock
and the difficulty with physical
meetings is that
you have to actually have to travel uh
to get to uh at the next meeting so he
attended a meeting in brentwood at six
and uh i'm sure broke no speed limits in
coming down to to rocksmith
so if i couldn't ask you counselor chris
hossack if you've tried to stand
thank you very much for joining us this
evening thank you
so if i may madam chairman i'll move on
i think you'd probably like me to read
out all the recommendations yes please
it is proposed that council resolves
that jonathan stevenson be appointed as
joint
chief executive stroke managing director
for both
authorities and designated as head of
paid service
from rochester district council with
effect from the 1st of august 2021
subject to legal agreement and
resolution by brentwood borough council
on 28th of july 2021
number two that the acting managing
director
and the assistant director legal and
democratic
in consultation with the leader of the
council engages with brentwood borough
council
and enters into an agreement under
section 113
of the local government act 1972 to
establish a joint
chief executive and head of paid service
for brentwood borough council
and rockford district council for an
initial period
of six months from the 1st of august
2021
and number 3 that the interim joint
chief executive
js and the two strategic directors
in consultation with the leader and
deputy leaders of each council
to undertake the creation of a
feasibility study
to explore further shared and
partnership opportunities with brentwood
borough council a further report with
proposals will be brought back to
council for consideration
by the end of 2021 and number four
that a maximum of twenty thousand pounds
be allocated from general reserves
to fund 50 of the costs required to
undertake the feasibility study
and provide additional program resources
brentwood borough council intends
subject
to council agreement to also commit
twenty thousand pounds of resources
to undertake this work number five
that the monitoring officer be given
delegated authority to make any required
changes to the constitution and finally
number six
that any delegate designated head of
paid service
is the proper officer under section 270
in brackets three of the local
government act 1972
i would like to propose those madame
chelly thank you councillor wilton
do you have a second uh councillor mr
thank you members are you happy to vote
for these recommendations on block
i would assume your agreement unless you
raise your hands
breed okay those members that are
for this recommendation please raise
your hands
nice and high
i just did
so
you can lower your hands now members
those that are against
please raise your hands
are there any members that would like to
abstain please
you can lower your hands now thank you
members
okay members that's 25
4 none against
and eight abstained so that is carried
thank you
members we will now move on to agenda
item number four
and that is announcements from
the chairman leader or head of paid
services
any of our guests if you wish to leave
you are welcome to do so now
in the meantime as chairman i would like
to make a short announcement
just to let you know that uh i've been
busy since the start of my chairmanship
role
firstly with a visit to east essex
hackspace which is my chosen charity
based at clements hall pavilion in
hawkwell
the committee members at hackspace were
pleased to hear that i have pledged my
support
by fundraising for hackspace this
municipal year
in addition the chairman for remap which
is an associated charity
invited me to be an advocate
highlighting the fantastic work they do
when using hackspace facilities by
making bespoke
apparatus or equipment for people with
disabilities
i have visited a few charities and
voluntary organizations including
junior park run corinthians football
association
for an award ceremony a charity event
for the avro vulcan
at south end airport which is totally
reliant on volunteers and fundraising
also the armed forces services held at
saint mary's church prittwell was well
attended
along with the mayor of southend council
and councillors
as well as the armed services more
recently
i was delighted to be invited to the nhs
73rd birthday and thanksgiving service
a joint ceremony with southend borough
council
furthermore i considered it an honor to
raise the nhs flag with the opportunity
to express my gratitude
and recognition for our nhs heroes
my fundraising continues with the
chairman's forthcoming garden party
being held on the 5th of august
at the lawns at rochford i welcome and
value everyone's support
and i will continue to update members at
each meeting
thank you
agenda item 5
public questions and and members
questions on notice
members there is a question from
councillor wilkinson
to the portfolio holder for governance
council wilkinson would you like to read
out your question
thank you chair good portfolio holder
for governors please give this council
reassurance
that she has put procedures in place to
ensure that the number of votes cast in
any council meeting correspond
with the number of members present at
the meeting and explain to this council
what those procedures are
we have seen examples recently where the
numbers have not been correct
yet the chairman has moved the meeting
on without this discrepancy being dealt
with
which can be seen in the minutes which
we've seen in addition can she also give
the members reassurance
that she has also put a procedure in
place to give clarity to members
when voting as annual council for
outside bodies
where there is more than one position
the last annual council
excuse me the last annual council saw a
great deal of confusion
where members did not know how many
votes they could cast
and the monitoring officer's explanation
at the time sadly did not assist
members need clarity moving forward so
that we all know how many times we can
vote
on a particular subject thank you
council mr wright
thank you councillor
the rules governing meetings of the
local authorities are partly found in
legislation
excuse me councillor thank you
are already procedures in place and
these have been clarified and explained
previously on numerous occasions
the local government act 1972 sets out
that matters are decided by a majority
of members
present and voting in an ordinary vote
the members do not necessarily always
equate
to the number of members entitled to
vote this is because
a member may vote for a motion against
emotion
they may abstain or they may choose not
to vote at all
if a member chooses not to vote that is
their prerogative
the officers will only count votes for
against or abstain
the situation is different for a
recorded vote because each member's
name is called and they are required to
state their vote
as for against or abstain
in a recent training session the same
question was posed to the trainer
who was an external trainer from the
association of democratic services
and the advice they gave supported the
monetary monitoring officer's advice
that the number of votes may not always
equate to the number of members
present unless it is a recorded vote
in relation to voting on appointments
rule
17.6 of the constitution applies where
there is one position
which only one person can fill but there
are several nominees
the constitution is silent where there
are multiple
positions and a multiple number of
nominees
it has been by convention that the
council deals with such nominations by
voting for each nominee
and the nominees with the most votes
fill the positions
members vote for each nominee as their
name is called out
and those with the highest number of
votes will be selected onto the outside
bodies
as is the case with many other
authorities each nominee is taken as a
separate vote
therefore members can vote each time for
each nominee
this is permissible in law and it
reflects to cust the custom and practice
of this council for many years
having con conducted my own review it
appears that 27 members out of 39
are very clear and content on this
procedure
thank you chairman thank you councilman
okay i think we can move on to the next
agenda item six business from the last
meeting
councillor mr wilkinson do you have any
further questions
thank you chairman thank you councillor
um thank you for
reading the constitution to us um with
respect it's not what i asked
um and saying 27 members voted for
something uh
out of 39 is not what i asked either i'm
not going to get an answer to my
question but
thank you i won't waste any of your time
thank you chairman thank you
would you like to answer that counselor
mrs rowe
thank you chairman my response earlier
was full and concise
and i now consider this matter closed i
have nothing further to add thank you
agenda item 6 business from the last
meeting
members does anyone have any questions
relating to the business from the
council meeting held on the 23rd of
february
2021
okay agenda item seven
to note the minutes of the executive and
committee meetings held between the
period of 10th
of february 2021 to the 6th
of july 2021 are these noted members
thank you
agenda item 8 to consider any reports
from the executive
and committees to the council item 8.1
report of the review committee annual
report
councillor mrs mcpherson
thank you chairman i'm already on my
feet
as vice chairman of the current review
committee and
as member of the review committee for
the 2020
21 year i am presenting this annual
report of the work of the review
committee for the 2021 year
to the full council this report was
recommended to full council by the
review committee on the 13th of april
unanimously by the review committee
on behalf of the review committee may i
thank last year's
chairman councillor jamie burton
and vice chairman councillor dave
sparing for their sterling work
especially in guiding this committee
throughout the pandemic
and keeping us to our work plan and
focused
thank you chairman thank you council mrs
macpherson
are there any questions members
counsellor newport
um thank you for presenting this report
to council
um i did have one question of the report
and i hope this is appropriate to ask
this question but
this was on the emergency planning
aspect of the report i wondered if the
scope of the report
on emergency planning was only
on rdc's emergency planning
the reason i asked this question
was because as someone that's used
the emergency phone number on the number
of times
i was quite alarmed to read here that
when it was tested by rdc that
it was satisfactory in line with the
requirements of the service
the number of times that i've called it
the lines failed to on one occasion be
answered
um on another occasion failed to help
at all when eventually um
i was able to speak with the acting
managing director
about the sanctuary housing problem
uh the acting managing director had to
and the leader of the council actually
had to
implement their own solution to the
problem
so my my question really is
mr newport sorry we're not discussing it
we're just receiving the report
i just wanted to ask a question on that
aspect of the report
i just wanted to find out if the scope
of the report went
to the partners as well that
provide services to the council
thank you
this recommendation is
council ahoy
given the answer to the previous thank
you
okay we have one recommendation set out
at the paragraph 2.1
on page 8.1.1 of the report
that council receives the annual report
is that received members
thank you
thank you chairman and just the clarity
um uh
councillor mr hoy if you don't mind me
saying you were on
the review committee that recommended
this report to full council
thank you councilman thank you chairman
chairman if i may in
response to council hoy's question this
is not a decision the report has already
been um agreed by the review committee
we are simply
asking members to receive the report
this evening
moving on to item 8.2
report of the review committee the
treasury management
annual review 20 21 to 22.
sorry 20 to 21. my apologies there
thank you madam chair um the treasury
management annual
review 2021 this item of business was
referred to the review committee
on the 6th of july this year with a
recommendation to note the council's
treasury management annual review
2020 to 2021. um
there's an extract attached to this
report of the key elements
from the assistant director resources
which has appended the portfolio holder
for finance although he's not here he
did make a very
valid point which this is a factual
report and it's a snapshot
of the work and the position of our
finances
at the end of the financial year there
was some discussion
during the review committee meeting and
that was around the
varying rates of interest
but those have been answered and the
information has been provided
by the assistant director resources
there's also some discussion about the
contract that we have with our advisors
link asset
and that's been cleared up that
they um they will be reviewed and and
the
re-tendered in the coming year
thank you chairman thank you councillor
wilson
so we have one recommendation to set out
in paragraph
1 to 2.1 on page 8.2
of the report that the contents of the
treasury management report be noted
is that noted members thank you
item 8.3 report of the planning policy
committee
the new local plan spatial options
regulation 18
consultation paper
members i will ask the chairman of the
planning policy committee
councillor sparring to introduce the
report
thank you chairman members
uh if you've had the opportunity to read
all these pages
you'll read there is a considerable
amount of evidence being submitted by
mr goodman and his team and on this
department
in relation to our ongoing local new
local plan
the work involved as you can see is
extensive
and has taken up considerable amounts of
time
i would like to congratulate officers on
what they've produced so far
and the way we are progressing with our
new local plan
having said that we have discussed
all three papers that are under your
consideration this evening
both at the working group and at the
planning policy committee
and i can quite happily itemize the
the the comments that we've asked to be
resolved
in due course if that's required however
during the course of the planning policy
it became evident that concerns despite
officers best efforts
as to how we would make sure that all
residents received the necessary
notifications
and request opportunities for their
input
that there could have been some members
of our community
that fall for wonderful better throws
through the gap
and wouldn't receive or be advised of
any of this correspondence
i took this on board and have discussed
this situation with the administration
and obviously there is no way that the
administration wants any of our
residents to not
be fully engaged with this opportunity
and i therefore
with your permission mr chairman would
propose
in addition to the other recommendations
that be resolved this evening
that i submit a motion that 45 000
pounds be allocated from
earmarked reserves to cover the the cost
of sending out
a consultation leaflet to all households
within the district
on the spatula options consultation
paper
and as necessary consultation leaflets
for potentially
up to a two further significant local
plan
consultation papers thank you chairman
if you wish me to
read through the items to be resolved by
this committee i will
otherwise if members are all happy i'll
leave it to you chairman
thank you thank you councillor do we
have a seconder for that
councillor ward thank you
would you like to read those out for me
certainly chairman
the first one is in relation to the
spatula options
regulation consultation paper and it
resolves that the special op options
consultation documents set out
in appendix a be consulted for a period
of six weeks
that the consultation is carried out in
accordance with the consultation
strategy
set out in appendix 1c
and lastly on that aspect chairman
the authority be delegated to the
assistant director place and environment
in course in consultation with the
portfolio holder for strategic planning
to make minor textual and cosmetic
changes
to the consultation document to ensure
that is factually accurate
and accessible at all time for the
consultation
thank you council sparring councillor
reeves do you have a question
thank you chair
very quiet
thank you madam chair i think we'll get
there in the end
um there were some questions i wondered
if we could ask who didn't ask if we had
any questions
on the motion before it was put forward
there has been some information that has
come to light
uh councillor hoy has questioned
uh essex county highways and it would
appear as though essex county highways
have thrown us on this matter into
complete disarray again members may not
be aware because this is very fresh news
essex county highways have commissioned
work on the highways structure
and future for the south of essex
that has only just been questioned uh
brought up
now councillor hoy has the email from
essex highways as i say he's only just
got that today
the problem is that they are talking
about the possibility
of garden villages and various other
infrastructure
points that would come up in the south
of essex now if that is the case
that throws our whole strategic
plan into disarray because how can you
put a consultation
out there when you don't know what the
outcome is going to be because when the
infrastructure changes
then the areas considered for
development
are going to change with it it's like
asking someone to dinner
and saying we're going to give you food
do you like it
we don't know what we're commenting on
this the whole of this
the new area plan because of what essex
highways have now put out
is is in question because it may not
once they've actually decided
on what they're bringing forward it may
well be
that the proposals for areas for
development may change
dramatically thank you councillor
councillor thank you chairman
uh councillor eves this is on the work
that we've done up till now
if things change in the future then that
will go into any future discussions we
have
and will be taken into consideration and
if we have to change plans
during the course of the next year or so
because of developments
that will be an ongoing saga but we are
giving a report
on what we were able to achieve up until
now with the information that we were
able
that was placed in front of us up until
our last meeting
which was on the 23rd of june thank you
council ahoy
thank you chairman um
this is uh a couple of things i think
this is quite premature given what
councillor
eve has just said i have emailed
councillor scott at essex county council
asking what
the plans for infrastructure planning
and assessment were within essex
and he has replied saying that there are
there is work being commissioned
and particularly with regards to
rockford which he regards as a a special
place which we all know it is however
also
in the report on page 8.3.2 in paragraph
3.2
so i'm trying to stare at the writings
very small and made it big enough
it does say that the council was
planning to commission an infrastructure
delivery plan
viability assessment and other evidence
within the next couple of months
which would identify the infrastructure
required um this was in answer i
can't remember if council of foster also
asked this question was
concerned about this question this area
as well because it seems we're asking
residents to make
a decision and we're consulting them on
the basis of
plans which we haven't yet decided and
which aren't
yet in place the that
response i've just read out at our last
meeting of the planning policy
committee was around the the judgment
that we're making the
failure of infrastructure as as low
where some of us argued that it should
be at least medium or high
given that we haven't even done an
assessment yet
um on that
basis i i i'm
and i'm aware that council sparring knew
that i had some doubts as well at the
meeting which
which he said was fair enough to bring
up at this meeting even though i voted
for it to come to this meeting um it
does give me
concern councillor waldon i believe has
also stated that he believes it should
be infrastructure first and
he has echoed concerns around
infrastructure in our meetings
i was voted on the platform of
infrastructure first
that we should be looking at the
infrastructure before anything else
because we know we have failing
infrastructure in this area
on that basis i'm i'm really struck i
cannot support this tonight because i
think we're
although we in some ways we are very
delayed i was arguing that this should
be coming forward about five years ago
as an early review of the local plan
however i think we're premature given
a big bit of work on infrastructure is
about to take place which could change
our plans completely
on the basis of what's happened with the
first local plan the current local plan
once this first stage is passed we we
find ourselves
in a situation where areas have been
chosen
if not specific sites areas have been
chosen which we are then tied to
regardless of what else may change and
that's what happened before
and that's where we had the problem
around the ashington road development
ser eight
in addition we were promised
a the members of the committee
the interactive map so we could see how
well it worked on different platforms
but i've not seen
a sign of that as either so i i really
cannot support
this tonight i really think we should
defer this
at the moment but i'm not sure i can
move deferment because we're still
debating an amendment i believe
as an additional motion thank you thank
you councillor
hi councillor wilkinson
thank you chair um whilst i have
everything sympathy
um with and gratitude in fact for the
recognition that some members of our
community we've missed out from this
consultation that it's quite right that
we do what we can to
encompass them all um first of all i'm a
bit concerned that this has come to
council as a motion without notice i
don't know why that wasn't added to the
agenda
but i'm sure it was legal i'm sure the
monitoring officer was consulted with
but moreover having heard what
councilors and councilor hoy have had to
say i wasn't aware of the email council
hoya had received
um my thought process therefore is well
if we're going to go ahead with this
consultation by spending an additional
45 000 pounds
how far down the line are we going to
spend an additional 45 000 pounds to do
it again because the first conversation
wasn't right so
um i think it's premature let's see what
this says
um and we cannot be spending any more
council money at this moment in time
thank you
thank you councillor wilkinson
councillor shaw
oh sorry council sparring thank you can
i just clarify
45 000 pounds has been allocated for
three
potential consultations it works out
about fifteen thousand pounds a time
so if the other two were not needed we
would not be spending forty five
thousand pounds
i'm going to take counsellor shaw then
steptoe stanley
and councillor fd uh in that order and i
think we've given their time
mrs shaw thank you i'm surprised
the other essex county councillors have
not had sight of this email
no i'm looking at uh councillor septo
he's as bemused as i am
so in that fact i don't think this
should be the email that um
councillor eves has mentioned that
council ohio has had
should even be discussed tonight because
no other member has seen it
thank you thank you councillor mrs
yes please i apologize chairman i should
have waited for the microphone
i just wanted to clarify that i also
made these remarks under page 8.3.2
paragraph 3.2 of the report
which says that the council was planning
to commission
an infrastructure delivery plan
viability assessment and other evidence
so that is basically saying the same
thing as the email i had from essex
county council thank you
does anything different councillor
steptoe
yes thank you chairman i just wanted to
comment that the
county level we are looking at and
working with
other councils on the a127 task force
that is yet to report and just to uh
not me for me to really correct
councillor hoy but the portfolio holder
for infrastructure
is councillor leslie wagland not
councillor lee scott
thank you councillor steptoe councillor
stanley
thank you councillor stanley
thank you chairman um just like to ask
councillor spearing er if um any
communications like this from essence
county council
that he should be aware of
of this communication and before
we actually send out the leaflets should
we be sending out any leaflets to the
residents that this is clarified with
him
before anything else happens thank you
thank you councilman stanley
councillors thank you chairman um i'm
not a county councillor so
i don't expect to have been notified
obviously as some of our own county
councillors haven't been notified i
don't know
why i should be put on there on their
shopping list with all these comments
that have been made i do have great
concerns
that here we are yet again trying to
push our local plan forward
and yet we keep getting opportunities
thrown at us as to why we shouldn't keep
moving the thing forward
if the world changes and other issues
can come up
then we will have to address them and
when we come to our next meeting
and when we come back to you again we
may well have had to have reviewed our
ideas
but i think as mr goodwin will tell you
this is a changing cycle
all the time we have to go with what's
placed in front of us at the time
and make our decision on the information
for all we know
the review from county may never get off
the ground it may disappear we've all
been down this road a number of times
before and i would
go back to members and say we've got
these recommend
resolutions for you and i would suggest
that we progress with this
and if subsequently down the road we
have to change or review
our operation or our presentation to you
then that's what we will do
as and when it's appropriate thank you
thank you councillor
final question councillor fd
thank you mr chairman um
one question a couple of observations as
david
said the uh local plan will
surely be uh looked at again after it's
finished and anything new will come into
it
um anything new also that comes up will
if it will go before the development
committee at the time
when it goes in so we can question and
look at it then
um and again how long will highways we
paul
take if it ever comes to fruition and
the actual question was if the council
resolves for this report when will the
consultation start the six-week
consultation start
i will refer to uh mr goodman over the
back there
how long will it take us mr goodman to
get the consultation out
next week there we are and it will be
going out to
all residents and it will be delivered
to all properties
thank you thank you councillor council
award does the
portfolio holder do you need to
yes thank you chairman um i i have to
echo councillor sparing's thoughts and
views
i think that this is a very very
important proposal for us to get our
plan
on the road and on the way and i do
appreciate the comments that that
council ahoy
made specifically to point
3.2 which is very very important
because what it does indicate is we will
be taking
into consideration new evidential
documents
that are brought forward and part of
that is the transport
and the transportation assessment that
highways are going to do
so we obviously will need to be looking
at putting this consultation out as it
stands
with the evidential documents enclosed
but as new evidence comes to light as we
progress
we will take that evidence on board and
use it
in regards to how we develop our
proposals
on the various sites and do they work or
not and i think that's a very very
important
factor that i think we all need to take
into consideration
and i just wondered where councillor
sparing
has put in uh motions one two and three
is the fourth motion also included well
we
we make sure that that is on there and
will we be taking
all of them as one motion that's
another question thank you and i fully
support
um the motions again as i said that
councillor sparing put forward thank you
thank you council award members are you
happy to vote these recommendations on
block
sorry
councilman would you like to put the
recommendation forward
i think i'll read them out again this is
in relation to
the uh special options regulation 18
consultation paper
that this bachelor options consultation
document set out in appendix a
appendix 1a be consulted for a period of
six weeks
counselor sparing we're just um um
you've moved uh a recommendation for if
you could just
recommend it what the motion
emotion okay thank you sorry if i
must misunderstood what you wanted that
45 000
be allocated from earmarked reserves to
cover the costs
of sending out a consultation leaflet to
all households within the district
on the special options consultation
paper
and as necessary consultation leaflets
for potentially up to two further
significant local plan
consultation papers that was the motion
check thank you council sparring do we
have a second uh
council award
okay so we're going to put that motion
to the uh
the members are you happy to vote with
these recommendations on block
sorry members um if i'm a chairman
absolutely um
members you've heard council sparing put
forward this recommendation can we
take uh we need to take a vote on it for
it to be accepted
as part of the four recommendations at
the end of this
report so chairman if we may can we take
a
um a vote yeah if you could raise your
hands
four
four recommendation four that uh
council is just read out
thank you members can i have your hands
for against
thank you members any abstentions
thank you members that's 29 4
none against and three abstentions
that motion is carrying so chairman
thank you that recommendation for put
forward by council has been accepted
so chairman you now have three
recommendations set out
at paragraph 1.7 on pages 8.31
and 8.32 of the report plus
the recommendation for you members have
just voted on
council sparing if you'd like to read
out all four thank you thank you
thank you thank you
the first one chairman is is in relation
to the
spatula options regulation 18
consultation paper
it's proposed that council resolves that
the special op
special options consultation documents
set out in appendix 1a
be consulted for a period of six weeks
that this consultation is carried out in
accordance with the consultation
strategy
set out at appendix 1c
and item number three on that that the
authority be delegated to
assistant director place an environment
in consultation with the portfolio
holder for strategic planning
to make minor textual and cosmetic
changes to the consultation document
to ensure it is factually accurate and
accessible
at the time of consultation the second
resolution
resolves that the council this is in
relation to the statement of community
involvement
that the statement of community
involvement 2021 review
at appendix 2a be consulted for a period
of six weeks
and item number three is the local
development scheme 2021
23.
sorry german that the local plans
development scheme 2023
set out in appendix 3ab adopted and
published on the council's website
and then of course chairman the motion
that has already been agreed thank you
chairman
thank you
so members are we happy to vote on block
on this
how many uh do we have can you raise
your hands if they're voting separately
please
okay thank you so we'll go back to
so it counts the hoyt i i miss
okay item one that the spatial options
consultation document
set out at appendix 1a be consulted on
for a period of 6 weeks
those members 4 please raise your hand
okay put your hands down please members
those members against
and those members abstaining please put
your hand down thank you
those abstaining
members we have 26 4
5 against and one abstain
that motion is carried
item two that this consultation is
carried out in accordance with the
consultation strategy
set out at appendix 1c
members those that are voting for please
raise your hand
chairman i think i think it should be
we've done that it should be in relation
i think chairman
to the statement of community
involvement
i believe we've done the first one this
is
the statement of community involvement
2021 review
at appendix 2a be consulted for a period
of six weeks
2.4 sorry council sparring we're still
on page 8.3 well you're taking all three
of them individually
yes okay okay sorry chairman
so that was item two the consultation is
carried out in
accordance with the consultation
strategy set out at appendix 1c
that please raise your hands
please lower your hands those against
please raise your hands
and those in abstention please raise
your hands
please lower your hands thank you
members that is 25 4 none against
and eight abstentions that is carried
thank you number three
that the authority be delegated to the
assistant director
place and environment in consultation
with the portfolio holder
for strategic planning to make minor
textual and cosmetic changes to the
consultation document
to ensure it is factually accurate and
accessible
at the time of consultation those that
are
for please raise your hand
please lower your hands those against
abstentions please raise your hands
thank you members please lower your
hands
there are four there are 25 four
none against and seven as pretensions
that is carried members
number four that 45 000 pounds be
allocated from earmarked reserves to
cover the costs of sending out a
consultation leaflet
to all households within the district on
the spatial
options consultation paper and as
necessary consultation leaflets for
potentially
up to two further significant local plan
consultation papers members
can i ask you to raise your hands four
thank you members you may lower your
hands
those against
thank you members and those abstentions
please raise your hands
that is 4 is 31
against is one and one abstention
members that is carried
statement of community involvement 2021
review
members i will ask the chairman of
planet the
planning policy committee councillor
sparing
to introduce the report
thank you chairman uh i think we've
pretty much
done some of these items to death
already members
but uh it comes under the statement of
community involvement
uh it's a proposal that council resolves
that the statement of community
involvement
2021 review at appendix 2a be consulted
for a period of six weeks
thank you chairman
thank you do you have a seconder
council award thank you
are there any questions
okay we'll go to the uh the vote
members those that are four please raise
your hand
members please run lower your hands
those against
please raise your hands
and any abstentions please raise your
hands
thank you members you can lower your
hands
members that is 32 4
none against and one abstention thank
you
that motion is carried
the local development scheme 21-23
members i will ask the chairman of the
planning policy committee
councillor sparring to introduce the
report
thank you very much gemini i think this
is probably the least contentious
uh item that we've been through this
evening and it
proposed that the council resolves that
the local development scheme
2021 to 23 set out in appendix 3a
be adopted and published on the
council's website thank you chairman
thank you do i have a secondary
council award thank you
members can those in favor please raise
their hand
oh sorry do you have any questions first
please put your hand down
no questions so please raise your hand
any four
please lower your hands those against
please raise your hands
and any abstention please raise your
hands
please lower your hands thank you there
are
27 four none against and
six abstentions that motion is carried
thank you
agenda item nine report on urgent
decisions
this is just for noting members i would
assume
that you agree unless anyone raises
their hands
that's noted members agenda item 10
report of the leader on the work
of the executive councillor wootton
madam chairman thank you very much
indeed um the
leaders update is set out on pages 10.1
and 10.2
and i have actually asked if it's
possible for
the leaders report to be circulated in
future agendas
it sets out the salient points of
business
in respect of three executive meetings
held on the 3rd of march
14th of april and 10th of june
minutes of the meetings have been
already distributed and set out those
items in more detail
and in addition there are the details of
six portfolio holder
decisions which have also been taken
now that concludes my abridged report
but members i accept it wasn't
circulated
in the agenda pack does anyone want to
listen to my voice anymore while i read
out the
full report madam chairman i will leave
that decision
to you for members to report back to you
thank you councillor
are there any members that would like
councillor high
council ahoy oh please sit down
councillor wooden i think there's a
question
uh thank you chairman it's uh obviously
a question
to this report but i have spoken to
councillor fd
immediately prior to this meeting on
this
but i think it's important that it's
brought up in the meeting as well
so i don't know if council of water
wants to answer the question or cancer
fd but i'll ask
the question first it's a bit of a
statement and a question um
in the report you refer to the the
that there's an agreement that free off
street car parking be provided for up to
30
nhs volunteers deployed at the kovid 19
vaccine nation centers across rochester
district um
it's really two questions there's been a
bit of posting on facebook today with
concerning nhs workers and or volunteers
who are paying for having to pay for
parking at the moment
so really the two questions are
there are 30
parking passes for 30 volunteers is that
enough is the first question
the second question is that the comments
were around the um
actual nhs workers paying to park
now i did check our website today and
the website is still saying
that nhs workers and carers on official
business
can still park for free in our car parks
i understand from council refugee that
may be outdated and should be updated
but i think there's a little bit of
contentious contention around this that
people feel that
nhs workers should not have to pay if
they're doing work at the vaccination
centers
they're the two questions i don't know
who wants to answer that thank you thank
you councillor
madam chairman with your agreement i
will i will defer to councillor fd his
portfolio holder
councillor fd
thank you councillor for your question
just for clarification
um nhs
workers are workers at these uh
vaccination centers are getting are
being paid to be there
so with the government relaxing the
car parking passes yesterday so it's no
longer
a government directive we took this
decision to
make park car parking passes available
to volunteers
who don't get paid for work in there i
don't see someone who doesn't get paid
for working there should have to fork
out
to park to help and we've consulted with
local
surgeries and managed practice managers
and
30 seems to be enough at the moment we
will of course keep that under review
if we need to have more we will look
into that then
hope that answers your question
um i spoke to matt earlier
after you asked me that question and
i think he's uh sorting that out it's
done so
let's go get me updated but of course if
anybody got a ticket yesterday
and our website wasn't updated we will
look at that
thank you councillor fd councillor
newport
and then councillor eves
thank you chair um in regards to the
marketing of the leasehold leasehold
opportunity
of the former crown hill public
convenience
could um the executive
please tell me how many expressions of
interest there has been to date
on that marketing and for what
term it will be marketed will it be
one year two years three years when how
long before a decision
on its permanent future is decided
please
thank you councillor newport
councillor wooden thank you madam
chairman
uh councillor newport um you possibly
extend the limits a little bit to uh
more than my information that i have at
hand tonight but i will ensure that you
receive a written reply to that
thank you councillorton councillor
reeves
thank you chair can i say uh thank you
to councillor wooden uh because one of
the things that i was going to ask was
that we get this
notification of the update from the
leader before the meeting because there
are a number of items in here that we
would really like to question
that we could have actually dealt with
outside of the meeting
um so rather than take up the time in
the council here
but thank you for doing that um there is
a concern in uh certainly in my group
where the update on the asset delivery
program
uh is at the moment uh we have raised a
number of
questions on notice and motions on
notice that have been refused
the peer review did castigate the
opposition parties for not using motions
on notice and questions and notices and
when we do
we are finding that they are being
blocked now
we are being given reasons for this and
i i understand that there are meetings
coming up
for this but in this particular case we
are
rather concerned and i'd like it to go
on record that we're rather concerned
that the reasons for these questions and
motions are notice being
refused has strayed into the political
arena rather than the operational
but uh that i just uh bring that as a
noted
uh following on from uh
uh james's point about the point of
order here
sorry thank you madam chairman uh i
think we really have i think councillor
eaves is rather pushing his luck this is
a
line item which talks about noting
a an executive and uh i admire
uh his creation creative approach in
trying to
uh open up a debate on the asset develop
delivery program
uh but that's really not what we're
debating tonight madam chairman i will
leave it to you
thank you thank you councillor eves
we'll uh we'll move on
to the the item of being noted thank you
thank you chair um moving on to the
um issue of the old public convenience
on uh the crown hill
i just wondered if you could throw light
on why it's taken so long to get it to
this stage it's been a number of years
that this building has actually remained
empty and it's an asset
that we haven't been drawing on that we
could have in the meantime wonder if we
had an answer to that thank you thank
you councilman
thank you madam chairman the crown hill
toilets you you
in raleigh um i will ensure a written
answer
which is fuller than the one i'm going
to give you now but i believe that
the opportunity to market those
toilets at the start of the pandemic
was much more favorable than it is
currently now i don't think there has
been a huge amount of interest at the
valuation that was put on it
at the start but i will ensure that a
more comprehensive answer
is sent to you in that respect thank you
thank you councillorton is that noted
members
thank you
agenda item 11 motions unnoticed members
there are none
okay members the time is moving on
and it's 9 20
and we've had a couple of hours so far
we need to
i think as a chair i'd like to move a
motion
without notice according to the
council's procedure rule 14.
that to extend this meeting beyond the
two and a half hours for as long as
practical
in order to complete the business can i
have a seconder please
counsellor dre
agreed members
thank you sorry
we can take a vote those in favor please
raise your hands
okay members you may lower your hands
those against
please lower your hands and those
abstaining
please raise your hands
thank you members that's 25 4 4 against
and no abstentions members we will now
take a comfort break for 10 minutes
and we will return at 9 30.
thank you
thank you members we will now move on to
agenda item 12 cctv
working group councillor williams will
you introduce the report of the cctv
working group
please one minute we'll get you a mic
thank you chairman thank you madam
chairman and members um
the purpose of this report is simply to
update members on the workings of the
cctv
working group also to endorse the use of
the community safety fund
to provide for capital funding in
support of cctv
and other safety initiatives should the
parishes
or town councils wish to take advantage
of
this fund uh to take advantage of this
funding that the administration has made
available
i therefore propose that this council
resolves to note the work undertaken by
the cctv working group
secondly to endorse the use of the
community safety fund
to provide for capital funding in
support of cctv
and other community safety initiatives
thank you chairman
thank you councillor williams do we have
any questions
oh sorry i need a seconder yeah thank
you councillor fd
uh questions i can see councillor
wilkinson
thank you chair um
thank you to councillor williams and um
i have got a couple of points to make in
relation to the report and it's unfair
of me to
throw these questions at councillor
williams because i already know he
doesn't know the answers because he and
i've spoken on the phone about it
there are a couple of concerns i have
with the report
the first is paragraph 6.1 of the report
talks about
parish implications i don't know where
that's come from
um council williams doesn't know where
that's come from
we discussed in the working group which
i've been a member of since the start
because obviously it was my motion to
brought this to full council
we've discussed unbeaten power supply
we've discussed
um gdpr discussed the issues never once
have we
ever discussed those responsibilities
falling on the parish councils
ever so i don't know why that's in the
report and i intend to find out why
that's in the report
my concern is that it's now causing
concerns for the two parish councils
that they
quite understandably won't want to
support it um
so i wouldn't want that on record please
the fact that that was not
ever discussed in the working group and
the report is inaccurate
in that regard however cctv
is very important
to most people i accept it's not
important to everybody
i accept there is a political element
that don't want it
however i have had contact from a number
of businesses
uh with regards to it all of whom are in
support
then
we talk about cctv reports
we're talking about the cc report
chairman which i'm referring to
councillor fd what's your
point of order
this is not about actual the cameras and
businesses wanting the cameras and stuff
like that this is about freeing up the
money
to actually for the town for the council
and for the parish
to actually make a decision yeah
chairman if i may there are two parts to
this
the first is to note the report i am
commenting on the report and the second
i will come to in a second if i may
but it's important if we're noting the
report that i point out the inaccuracies
of the report yes which you've done
yes which i've done yes thank you then
you go on to say about local
you've been in touch with local
businesses local businesses i'm in touch
with you
about ctv cctv chairman perhaps if i
speak out of return then correct me but
if i'm not then perhaps the
interruptions could stop
can we just let kathy wilkinson finish
his point please thank you very much
so this is supported by everybody and i
do endorse
the use of the community safety
fundraiser and i will support that
however and this is a however
i have grave concerns with regards to
the wording
of the motion um because it's too bland
councillor wilkinson i'm sorry to
interrupt but it is an emotion this
this point there is a motion chairman i
wish to move an amendment to that motion
this is for noting no the second part of
the motion i believe
i may be wrong
okay so for the 0.2 then yes
if i can finish please
right thank you so i wish to make an
amendment
if i may to the second part of the
motion
which is just the second part to endorse
the use of the community safety fund to
provide for capital funding
in support of cctv and other community
safety initiatives which i have no issue
with which is what it says
however there is no control there is no
governance attached to this there is
nothing
so therefore i would like to add each
community safety initiative application
will need to be assessed
against a set criteria by all three ward
members
for the award in which initiative is
located together with the portfolio hold
of the community before funding
is allocated thank you chairman thank
you
do you have a second council with
councillor williams yeah yeah thank you
councillor we'll continue
your your points are noted and made well
um
as far as i'm aware the report has not
yet been received by rayleigh
uh town council i've just been informed
they've not received the report there
will be an updated report
um it would be unfair at the moment to
to put that
that that amendment forward in as much
that you would then um
possibly put district town council
against parish councillors one approval
or or rejection would affect the other
so
i think as it is at the moment it should
go forward as originally
uh and proposed thank you
sorry councillor wooden
thank you very much indeed madam
chairman um
i attended the last meeting of the cctv
working group
and there was uh enthusiasm to make sure
that it appeared on the agenda tonight
and i made a call in that meeting and
i'm grateful to
uh officers for putting it on the agenda
tonight
um it becomes a bit of a chicken and egg
situation
in the sense of you don't really know
whether or not you're going to get the
money until you actually get the money
and you you know what comes first the
offer
or the money i am particularly proud of
the fact that this administration
in a time of financial difficulty
through
uh kovid pressures was in a position to
actually continue to
invest in the community in a range of
activities
and i'm particularly proud of the fact
that we were able to set aside
100 000 pounds for community initiatives
including cctv
and i think that is where we ought to
major on this report
but i do accept from councillor
wilkinson
that in some haste i believe to get it
on the agenda tonight
i do not believe it has been totally
thought through
what role this authority will take
versus the parish or the town council in
respect of the actual
nuts and bolts of the implementation of
the scheme
so i do accept there is more work to be
done
but what council wilkinson has to accept
with respect
is the fact that some of the activities
in terms of the
ongoing management of any cctv program
will be down to gdp gdpr
and the need for licensed registration
with the body that is actually
responsible for the ongoing management
so the report tonight really talks about
the provision of finance
it doesn't go into the fine detail of
the actual operation of how cctv
works or will work and i would just urge
members to focus
on the community safety fund of which
this administration is proud
thank you madam chairman thank you
councillor
do you have a question
thank you uh it's not a question but
we're already debating emotion which is
being proposed and seconded as i
understand it
um i entirely understand councillor
wilkinson's
comments about it i've i've got concerns
around the report and i think
councillor wooden probably
hinted at my concerns as well that i
think it's probably
this report has probably been brought
here prematurely i think
i'm i'm a bit concerned that that
there's a hundred thousand pounds
um in a community safety fund but i
can't see
how it's being controlled how you apply
for it
any more detail upon it says two and a
half
thousand pounds for community safety
initiatives i've got no idea what that
means to be honest
i'm not sure what the roles of rainy
town counts
really town council and which repairs
accounts are here if both rtc and rpc
accept the proposals there's a
total capital expenditure with remaining
money's been available for grant for
other parishes within the financial year
so it's it's it's like we voted for
something for really town council and
radio parish council
but we've sort of forgotten about other
parishes i know holbridge has got quite
an extensive amount of
cctv which they do use they might want
to update but they've been left out
um they may have been given the
opportunity but there's been an election
since then
so i i will support
the amendment because i think it gives
some
it's controlled around how the money's
being spent and how it's being applied
for
and if it's been applied in the right
place but um
i'm still struggling to to really
support it overall because i just think
it's premature
thank you council lahoy we'll go to
councillor williams and then we'll go to
the amendment
yes thank you madam chairman
um no parishes have been left out all
parishes
and i repeat all parishes will be able
to claim
up to 2 500 pounds in match funding
this sorry right so
this is in its very early stages the
governance of yet has yet to be decided
so
i i i fully expect you know i hope
um certainly hope that this this
recommendation to to an enable funding
for this
project will go ahead thank you
thank you councillor williams uh
councillor wilkinson
do you need to speak on the amendment
james thank you for letting me come back
before this put to the vote um
just to clarify a couple of points that
i made um i do understand and i think
there's been some confusion the points
that i was trying to make
um i am not criticizing the
administration putting the side a
hundred thousand pounds in fact i voted
for it i
supported the budgets so i'm not um
criticizing them in any way shape or
form i'm simply saying
that in this motion that we're asking to
be voted on tonight there's no
governance
involved and that's what i was asking
for um and my comments were more noting
about
the uh the cctv or the the paragraph 6.1
um and i'm surprised although obviously
i don't disbelieve counselor williams
but i'm surprised because
he will remember of course at the
meeting that we were at wednesday the
council alumnly
as chair of the community safety group
on the town council was quoting from the
report
um so i i am surprised the saying that
the parishes don't have it but
i'll obviously take his word for that
but thank you thank you councillor
williams cat sorry council wilkinson
council williams do you need to come
back thank you i think the report that
council alumni was referring to was the
one
made in i think 2020 i believe
but i have been assured this evening
that that rayleigh town council
has not yet received the report so it
would really be unfair of
on rocher parish council at the moment
if we were to make a decision on that on
those grounds
thank you thank you councillor wilkins
councillor lawman do you have any points
as the seconder
hey chairman directly no but listening
to the discussion and i'm not involved
in the uh
cctv part group or anything like this
but it does concern me that when we talk
about the parishes if we don't get the
word improper
correct and it's misleading here to me
because it talks about implications
which is i think what we've been talking
about here that's how i understand it
i mean item really item six
it talks about parish implications but
i've got another half here talking about
finances so why are we talking about
implications
this it's a little bit confusing this
document and and i do see where people
are coming from but if we're going to be
asking
all the parishes to take part we have to
be mindful
of their limitations and we don't want
to exclude people
because we can't get it right in the
first place that's my
and i do agree i think this is premature
and i'd like to see this deferred
probably to the next meeting
so that the relevant officers members
can get together
and resolve the questions and we can
have another look at it but at the
moment it seems a little bit un
unstable that's my view thank you
council norman
councillor wilkinson would you like to
read out
your amendment please
okay uh chairman but the amendment is
sir for
number two only to endorse the use of
the capital sorry
start again to endorse the use of the
community safety fund
to provide for capital funding and
support of cctv
and other community safety initiatives
each community safety initiative
application will need to be assessed
against a set criteria by all three ward
members for the ward in which initiative
is located
together with the portfolio holder for
community before funding
is allocated
okay members we will vote on this
amendment if you can raise your hand if
you are
in for the amendment
please lower your hands members that
are vote voting against
please lower your hands
any abstentions please raise your hand
members that is ten four
twenty 2 21
against and two abstentions
unfortunately that amendment is not
carried
so we're now going back to the original
council ahoy do you have a question
thank you um chairman um i'm just
speaking to the original motion now
um i i just i won't okay what i've said
again i've got concerns about this
i'll just draw your attention to
paragraph 2.7
on page 12.1 in the event that the
proposals are not progressed by either
ready town council or rochford
parish council any unspent monies from
the community safety fund will revert to
the general fund
now i'm reading that as though if they
don't take part there is no there is no
community safety
fund of 100 000 pounds i just want to
know if i'm correcting my interpretation
i think if i'm interpreting it like that
other people can interpret it the same
way as well
and that's my concern that as has been
said if
ray town council haven't seen this we're
proving something they've not seen there
may not be
a fund we're approving it before we even
know that it's going to work
and that's my real concern
if there is a hundred thousand pounds
and it's available to other parishes in
part two and a half thousand pounds each
then that's quite good but if it's only
dependent on the
on the agreement of ready town council
and russia parish council agreeing to
this
scheme overall then i can't support it
i've got real difficulties
with it thank you thank you council
lahoy
councillor williams yeah thank you
chairman it's not dependent on
on on the fact that rochefort district
or rochester
richard parish or rochford o'reilly town
council
take up this offer the money will be
there if we if
if we agree to the the use of this
funding this evening
if the parishes want it that's purely
they have to make an application the
governance share is to be decided
but if they want it the money will be
there for the parishes regardless
of whether town council or parish
council takes up the offer for cctv
thank you
are there any more questions
councillor mcpherson
sorry chairman it's um literally just on
the back of what councillor hoy just
mentioned
um when it says fund uh the safety fund
will refer to the general fund
is that our um rocha district council
general fund
or is that this csp general fund
so will the money that isn't used to go
back into community safety initiatives
thank you councillor macpherson council
williams are you able to answer that
thank you chairman
um i have to say i don't know the answer
to that perhaps i could ask on
officer louis somos to answer that one
oh sorry louie louise moss
yeah chair it will go back to the
council's general fund
not the community safety budget
thank you we will now move on to the
vote
so those that are for
this motion please raise your hands
so remembers this is uh for noting on
number one and
for voting on the second
motion sorry chairman if i may
assist members there were no
questions so uh sorry please leave your
hands uh members there were no real
questions so the chairman has taken it
to a vote
uh members there are two recommendations
set out in paragraph 8.1 of the report
on pages 12.12
and 12.3 members the first
recommendation is to note the work
undertaken by the cctv working group
members is that noted
and and then we'll move on to to where
we're
yeah and if you could vote
those in favor four please raise your
hands
please lower your hands those against
please raise your hands
and please lower your hands any
abstentions
can you keep your hands raised please
okay members please lower your hand
there are 23 four three
against and seven abstentions
that is carried members and that
concludes the business for this evening
at
9 55. thank you for
attending the members please rise once
the
chairman and the captain retired